some positive testimony you've had um
you know you were talking about
strategizing earlier and how
um you you know you you've built Bridges
with a lot of really great celebrities
who can get the word out and things like
this one of those people
um historically was was Tom Delong who
who helped with to the staff and things
like that and you you guys used to be
chummy and I kind of wanted to ask you
know what happened between you and Tom
why did you drift apart
well we did and he got intercepted by
some folks who had sort of brainwashed
him of the alien threat narratives uh
General mccaskill at Wright-Patterson
and other people and uh he got led by
his nose down that Primrose path and
then of course he had all kinds of of
dark players like Elizondo and uh Simi
band Jim Simi band who's CIA and other
people kind of circle around him and I
think he just got used and abused and
then dumped which I had predicted would
happen it was unfortunate uh but the
problem was having a little bit of
knowledge in this area it's very easy to
get manipulated by these sort of uh
professional
counterintelligence operatives so when
my what I saw happen is that Tom kind of
got intercepted because they saw him as
someone who could be a front man to open
up this with a certain narrative
to a very specific demographic you know
younger people and that is
um with with this sort of these are a
threat to the National Security and oh
by the way we don't know what they are
but of course we do know what they are
we put out a film last year called The
Cosmic hoax that documents how all this
was done
um but I think that in his case I I
actually don't it was quite some years I
mean he's had come out and stayed at my
house out here in Virginia in the
mountains at near University of Virginia
and I've been at his place and we did
some things but that was
I'm trying to think early 2000s or so
what have you
um so I just think that what happened
and and he mentioned some of this to me
when we were out there he had a he was a
a girlfriend or
at the time whose uncle was involved in
these projects and I think he started
getting targeted to get pulled away from
you know actually staying on an accurate
path and he got intercepted by
counterintelligence people who are very
good at doing that because that that's
one of the real problems is that if they
look like you could be an asset to be of
some value
then there's going to be an attempt to
pull you over
uh and and feed you false information
but also false narratives but he was
predisposed to that anyway the whole
Alien Invasion thing which I always find
laughable any Sciences you know oh yes
you're coming from another star system
with Technologies a hundred thousand
years past what we have
and they they're invading us how where
the whole thing is ludicrous
um but it's of course how you would
build the future of the military and
Industrial and financial complex around
another enemy because I think that's
exactly what Verner Brown shared with
Carol rosin on his deathbed this has
been a long-term defense plan to sort of
present a threat from out there where
the world can get United but instead of
in peace it's going to get united
through another Boogeyman we all need to
fight because ultimately the public is
controlled through fear and demagoguery
and and this is the ultimate demagoguery
and fear in my opinion just for the
record I apologize if my attitude is
dismissive I don't mean that and when I
ask for evidence or for a paper I do
that with everyone including aviloby
said that so-and-so came from outside
I didn't bring a 500 000 page archive in
here to hold up every time you ask about
something but I've given people the
resources go and find it
um you know now eventually what we want
to do with this is a PDF searchable
archive where all this will be you know
you put in boom and it comes up that'd
be great but yeah so you guys since you
guys are rich podcasters can help fund
that I wish I'm just gonna because we're
talking about you know 500 000 to a
million dollars to create that